I pay to watch you [ __ ] somebody for a
couple minutes you would it be funny
would you laugh I think you will here's
what I would do
yeah I would probably order a coffee or
something do I
but during it like I'd watch but it also
be like yeah I'm one just like a medium
with almond milk please
and then you know that way I'm watching
and I'm cheering you on it like the
World Cup a little bit there's this dude
named Mike Burton he's a comment uh-huh
and we did this get him Burton's son
isn't it no it's not Tim Burton's son
he's sure I don't know but Mike Burton
oh wait I [ __ ] know like Burton you
know Mike it's more like little and I
would be like a juvie yeah yeah prov
maga Wray Wray wrestling he do one time
he put his own self in a headlock and
choked himself
yeah accid I dude yeah and I'm just yeah
I did it with that dude yeah I mean it
was a feature a girl I was opening
mm-hmm and he convinced her cuz she did
a bit about on stage about having a
threesome so afterwards my Burton cuz it
would you have one with me and Bob sick
okay we go to the hotel room right now
and are you nervous or something no I
mean I couldn't believe it right
and you couldn't believe what that he
would include me and y'all are the same
height I know it's cute yeah it is very
cute affair and but I see him being like
aggressive and wanting to win the
threesome is all weird I thought I can
do it and you know what I'm happy to be
that guy yeah to be like on the outs I'm
happy to lose a threesome
what do you mean I'd like to do it but
also like I don't need to come in first
place there's always the do that he's
coming for a second for sure yeah I'm
like the tag team guy Yeah right you go
do your thing
Yeah right there's a hero then you come
in and take a whole body slam you be the
head chef right you'd be the head chef
Alba do it I'll do desserts
that's what that's like that right so
he's we get naked uh-huh and they both
just start cackling oh wow with laughter
when they see my body home but yeah I'm
laughing too right but I did it anyway
but the whole time why you'd never eat
seen your body before they've never seen
my body though right what are you
laughing at cuz they're laughing at my
body okay they're laughing so hard it
makes me want to laugh I think you know
waiting your whole life to see your body
and this is when you decided to do it
no no that's not it I had seen my body
do have mirrors yeah but you could also
not see your body if you want like I'll
go sometimes you know armor once I went
like eight months without seeing my legs
I understand that but what I'm saying to
you right now is that I don't think even
cavemen back in the day yeah where they
didn't have mirrors and they weren't
that bright they've seen their own legs
at least yeah they've even looked inside
a pond and seen the reflection of their
face yes there's no one on the face of
this planet
that has an IQ over 50 that's never seen
it right they've all seen their bodies
on their faces what you're saying is I
would dig you think everybody everyone
that's ever lived on the face of the
planet you're saying that because you
experienced no no I'm saying that what
I'm saying that is if you're a baby
right you don't know what a circle is
right right you don't you know you'd
like even like a triangle your turn in
your head what is that right that's one
thing but if you're over the age of five
let's just say anyone over the age of
five over the IQ of 50 they've all seen
their bodies in their faces yeah over
the age of 50 but you guys no no 50 um
IQ I'm in oh I don't know if that has
anything to do with it I think if you're
around long enough you get to see your
full body and when they don't know that
then I wouldn't argument though I'm not
arguing about this at all I was just
saying for eight months I decided not to
see it look at my own leg
that's all I was saying yeah and I did
it and it's a new Expedia you don't have
a new experience you're like oh [ __ ]
when you finally reveal your own legs to
you it's a so you did that to your Wow
you take a diet it's like a V yeah I did
that with I was a vegetarian for a month
yeah there you go same thing it's not
this sounds like a leg Italian dude
you're like a terrier yeah but anyway
that is your [ __ ] story man
I don't even know what I was talking
about at the strip club they laughed at
your body yeah yeah no way so we were
cackling but you know she would be
blowing him and I would be down eating
her out
wow really yeah at the same time now we
would be our you're getting secondary Oh
if she's full you're eating her if she
never bloom it you're awaiting her out
you're getting secondhand I'm doing all
the groundwork Oh still no riot it's
like you owe you like a centipede kind
of a thing yeah yeah like a centipede
kind of thing
good afternoon and other times thanks
for watching that video you just saw I
mean it was okay but the next video you
can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one